Hello everybody! My name is Markiplier and welcome to Right Click to Necromance.
Now I'm not 100% sure about this, but
I'm preeeeeety sure that this has nothing to do with
that "Dance of the Necromancer" game.
Crypt of the Necromancer...?
Necromancing  Crypto Dancer *ok Mark good try*
Necro-crypto-dancing-pants
Right Click to Necromance
Either way this is made for a GameJam
Sometime last year, and it involves
*Distracted* Oooh hello.
Hi...? Ohhh
Hi! Hello everybody!
My name is Markiplier. I'm here to kill you
Hey, you wanna fight? *realizes he may be fucked* Ohhh Shit   ;o
OH Damnit. They're so cute!
WHOA!  *Mind blown*
That's awesome!
Necromance awayyyyyy!    Wait -.-
I just need to kill people and then they come back?!
Oh shit, that's not good... *Rekt* AAAAGH
*sulks like a baby bitch*
Oooh Nooo!
I DIED!!  *oh really?*
Well, what was I s'pposed to do?!
I mean obviously not suck
and deal with Assness     *wait assness?*
Deal with....*realizes that makes no sense* NOT
SUCK AND BE TOTAL ASS
Ok, so I gotta go for the small groups first.
*Mark noises*
Boink! Ok, so
Once you get the small groups dead
You can get MOOOOOREEE!
...Eh....
K...Come here you!
*Creepy laugh* I like this...>:)
It's like exponential growth!  Heyyy,
Hey buddies! Hey friend.    *sound cool yet?*
You're all alone! That's a mistake >:)
*Mark noise* Why can't I
Necromance? I wanna Necromise ;~;
Oooh, ok. YOU WANNA FIGHT?! *so tough*
*tone of regret* Oh boy, this is a lot of people
More people than I anticipated! AGHHH
They're coming after me! *Defeat Screech*
NooOOOOoOO! Damnit, God Damnit.
This is harder than I thought it'd be, I mean
I didn't know anything it would be so I didn't think anything
going into this  *Marks distracting screech*
Euyuyuyuy!   we  'gon gitcha!
*rip Marks army...?* Ugh, I think they got us
Ok, get these guys? Alright, well we got a lot of competition over here
Ok, stop killing ma dudes!
I need more dudes! Whoooaa. Let's avoid them
Ok, so the field ain't too big
Sooo...
I just need to let them NOT conglomerate everywhere
HEY, oh, HEY (x2) ehh
Hey heeey (x4) Whoa! Hey Buddy!
You are big. I did not know you were there
Can I eventually Necromance that guy?
K, get these guys. Get 'em up.
Kill 'em, kill 'em! Kill Dem! KILL THEM DEAD!
Ok, you. You group of four.  *yes?*
I can take ya. You think you're tooof?! *attempted Scottish accent* You think you're TOOOF?!
Oh geez.  A group of five coming in
But as long as I get the four I'll be fine!!!!
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes! Ok.
Now we got a big army goin' on here :)
A big, GIRTHY ARMY.
Hey, you wanna join my army?
Not that you have much of a choice...
Also, why are random soldiers just staying around in a random field, somewhere in a random place?
Ok, you're dead.
Uhhhh, yer dead
All of you's gonna be dead
Yup, you cannot withstand my girth
Join my girthy nature
Alright, you: Group of seven, huh?
Tooo bad you're still gonna die
We gottem surrounded
Dead; alright, you, ALL of you
Everybody come on in
The water's warm inside my pile.
OH geez, OH god: That's not Good
Well.
Alright, big fight!
*Mark's charge screech*
We're gonna win! We're gonna win! WE'RE GONNA WIN!    We're gonna win at heavy losses, but we're gonna win nonetheless.
Hit eh, hit eh, hit eh, hit eh, hit eh
Hey-ya duh ho duh *Marky noises*
Aaaaaand, you're all dead
*Satanic Mark* Yes
I don't know if we gained any more, or lost everybody.
Whoa, they're bigger. Let's NOT go for the bigger ones, just yet.
Ha-buh-duh, ha-buh-duh, ha-buh-duh, ha-buh-duh!
This games cool! I actually like it!
Whoop, there we go.
Ha-buh-da, hoo-bi-di
Let's see... Woop!
There we go!
Alright, are you stuck on a rock over there, or are you trying to hide behind it?
Well, you can't escape your fate, so...
Wait, where's your buddy?
Where's the rest of ya?
Alrighty then.  Got them.
Hello!  Before I fight the big guys, I wanna pick on the little-r guys
'Cuz that's what Markiplier DOES!
He exploits people's weaknesses!
If you can even call it a weakness, just... sheer outnumbering 'em.
Hey, you're-- *sees a scary* BWAAAAAAYE!
Scary, scary, scary.  SCARY!
Ok.  You know what?  Uh oh, they're coming.
They're-- Alright, let's do this!
*Markiplier shriek*  Ahhhhh!
Oh God, that's not gonna work, is it?
Agh, they're too STRONG!!
NooOOO!
Noooooooo!
Get 'em!  Kill 'em!  Oh jeez, this is not what we're looking for.
*yelling to his troops* Kill the big guys first, if you can!
If you can't... You know what, good effort, team!
Good hustle out there!
You-- You didn't do what you were supposed to do, but you tried!
And that's all that matt-- *dies* oh, fuck you guys, you guys suck...
I thought the last minute encouragement would have been enough to make you not be a bag of dicks!
This is actually pretty clever.  Like, I've never seen a game like this
It's just kind of a unique style of game that I haven't experienced before.
*high pitched squeak* but it's pretty cool!
I gotta admit, they're, der, doin' -- der, dey're doin' a purdy good job here!
Dis, dis is pretty good for being a jam game.
This is really good!
It's simple concepts like this that just make a game FUN.
Because that's what a game SHOULD be.  It should be some sort of fun.  One would hope.
Get 'em, get 'em.  Get 'em all.
Ha-buh SPLOOSH.
Okay, got you.
It's like a virus spreading aro-(*mini burp*)-und.
But a virus being random people on a battlefield.
And I'm assuming I'm zombies?  We're a Necromancer, so we're raising people from the dead.
So I...
It would be under the assumption that everybody here is perfectly justified in their attempting wanton murder of us
Because we're horrible creatures from beyond the grave.
We're literally their friends that have come back from the dead
And not in the good way!  In the horrible, oh-my-god-you're-a-zombie way.
Your soul has been possessed, the lich king is attempting to absorb your power, that kind of thing.
They're trying to HIDE.
You can't hide from me! *deeper voice* you can't run away...
Alright, so I'm getting big enough -- I'm getting GIRTHY enough --
That, hopefully, some bigger packs are gonna come by
And give me plenty of soldiers...
Yes, thank you.  Yes, thank you.  Please don't resist.  Thank you.
Your efforts are futile, you shall be assimilated.
Okay, there's a big crew over there, don't know if I'm girthy enough to beat them.
OHH, they're coming.  Alright, welp.  Time to test it!
I think I'm... Ah, I think I'm gonna win this one easy.
Huh duh duh, der der der *faster* deer deer deer deer de de duh duh duh.
Ohhh, that's not good though.
Hooo-kay.  No no no.  No.  Get back!  Get back!  RUN!
RUUUUUUUN!
Okay, they're gonna stay there?  Okay, they'll run away.  Alright, that's good.  You know what?  That's good.
Got 'em.  Nailed 'em.  Alright.
Alright, so I got a big crew here, but what I gotta do is I gotta not be swarmed-did.
You wanna... Phew.  They were GUNNING for it.
They were gunning for it BAD (like the fangirls?) Okay, they're coming over here.
Run, run, ruuuuun!
ReTREAT!
Okay.  STOP RETREATING!
Press onward!  Form the shape of a DICK!
They're gonna come down here, so if I could...
naw, those five are gonna frick me up, dude.
They're gonna mess me the F up.
K, there's a big crew, but they're followed by... 3 big dudes.
Oh.  Hello, hello!  Ammo, yes!
What's with the big old wizard dude?
I'm not ready to fight that guy!
Wooh.  Woah woah WOAH  RUUUUUuuuuuun!
I'll take you, yes please, join my army.
Join my crew.  I'll take you (a worthy slogan) Okay, bye bye
Eugh!
Hello. AHH!
TOO MANY!!  Muuuurgh!
I need this group!
Ohh, just... AWWW!  ACK!
N'AAOOOW!  TOO BIG!  RUN AWAY!!
RUN!  Okay...
Good thing they give up real easily.
Okay, so that's a tactic that you need to do, you need to actually run away from these people!
Okay, this group is gonna be mine.
Assimilate!
Okay, got them.  Alright, I'm not gonna -- I'm not gonna tango with the big guy.
Alright, they're stuck on a rock, but that's good enough for me to rock them!
*Drum  noise*  Ba-dum CHING!
OHHH, that ain't good.
That ain't good!  Okay, nope!  Not joining that fray.  Get out!  Get out!  Bail!  Bail!  Bail!
CHRISTIAN BALE!!
Oh fuck.  Oh fuck, dude.
Ooooh nooo!
OOOOH NOOO, DUDE!
*concerned Markiplier sound* Yeee...
There's some dead people there, but I haven't killed the whole cre-- There are SO many people!
There are so-- I'm gonna assimilate this group here!
You're MINE!  Don't join the fray.
Do NOT!  DO NOT JOIN THIS-- Okay, thank you.
Oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, oh my god, ah gee-- YES!
Ok get them.  Yeah.  Okay.
Somehow-- No!  My BUDDIES!!
Where did you come from?!
You know what?  We're going for it!
Ah, frick, this is the end of me...
Ohhhh God, get that crew, get that crew, get that crew-- YES!
Ah, we're fighting on two fronts here, why?  NooOO!
Get these guys-- I want you in my army!!
YES!  We got big guys!  Okay, we got big guys.
We got some big guys.  Which is going to help us
Because now I can take on *other crew skedaddles in the other direction* nope, apparently not...
OOohh, not that guy.
This is SOOO much more difficult than I thought it'd be.
Alright, you know what, I'm going for you guys, I don't know how tough this is gonna be...
Gonna be pretty tough, ain't it?
*Mark Noises*
Give me one of you-
I want you!
I want you in my group
Can you-everyone please
There we go
Yess
I don't know-oooh
Those guys are bigger
Ok.
So we're doing OK,we're doing OK.
Nope, not them
Not them... I'm picky, I'm picky
There's a lot more strategy to this than I thought there'd be
Cause they are not very forgiving when you don't have the right people inbound
Okay got them- *weird, concerned sound*
This-this big guy does help. Let me try to get this group.
Yes- yeah- yeah- YES
YESS and yes. Okay good, good
We're doing much better
Much better than we WERE doing
I need to take this big group on if I- woah
Not that guy
Why are small guys still here? Alright i'm going to swarm them.
Get them- get them down- get around them, get around them, get that guy down
Woah that's- that's too many peeps. That's a lot of peeps
Oh no... Oh no...
Those big guys, they're too tough. Oh God.
Oh no. Oh no! Oh n-nothing? Oh boy
Alright, you know what? Ok, well this did not go according to plan. *Oh really?*
Alright can I take these guys on?
One guy take down all these dudes? *Probably not*
Can we eventually cycle down to something a bit more manageable for me-NOPE!
Alright! Well he died, alright that sucked.
But it's getting better! It's not good but it's getting better.
I think, I think the problem is like I need to encircle people? But...
It's kinda hard to do.. that.
Get 'em.
Get 'em!
Got eem
The advantage versus the big guys is that you can...
You can have a whole bunch of people wailing on him at once and they can only hit one at a time.
Circled!
Spread out!
FAAAN OUT!
Nice, ok, this is going better! This is going a lot better than it was
Circle around, circle around, and close in.
Kill 'em! Slaughter them!
okay here we go big crew
alright going around em around em around em
yea I was afraid of these big guys but I really shouldn't have been
okay got big guys in the crew now
okay good. we're doing WAAAY better than we were, like WAAAY better
infinitely better
alright you want some of this?
well good thing we're all about the surround 'n' pound
cmon get em'
cmon guys you're better than this!
cmon guys... CMON GUYS!
oh cmon! *more frustrated*
YES! okay.. got big guys in the crew
what'cha gunna do?!
'kay got them... OH GOD NO..
oh god no..
oh god..
this is not what we intended
but okay, i-it's what we got
okay
there we go, got em
okay got those guys
*disturbed Mark noises*
this is just... very stressful
there we go, big army
oh that's actually really cool, the the like skull faced guys they split em up
so that there's more- they space em out so that we can surround em easier
I'm ALL about surroundin' em
I guess the eventual goals is to be able to, to kill the the big guy in the bottom left maybe
I have no idea if that's actually the goal but that's actually pretty cool
if that is
got those guys
OVERWHELMING NUMBERS
okay you you guys you're are coming with me
I don't care if you are the bigger versions of em
you're getting surrounded
and you're getting murdered
c'mere you
c'mere you!
C'MERE YOU
*mark noise* I've still got some little guys in my crew
I'M GUNNA HELP
oh no you're gunna die
I think we're pretty much getting unstoppable here
we've reached a ~girthy~ size
which is ONLY.. going to be the best.
oh hello! ...mini guy.. oh shit dude!?
fuckin' shit dude
that... alright.. so we got a got a mini dude in our way which is helpful, question mark???? I think so?
nICE!
NICE!!
oKAY I'm gunna go for the guy..
oooh wait no I'm not *gets distracted*
I'm gunna get these guys first
no don't! *disturbed Mark noise* wizard man don't be in front
wOA HELLO.. big crews. oh my god..
well.. maybe...yea, good thing I.. I didn't do it too soon cause
holy shit, oh my god we're being attacked from all sides here
we gotta get these guys in, yes! the crew
spell caster is still protected!
okay good.
okay I think, I *think!* we're, we're probably pretty good here
we're probably doing just fine
wait where's the rest of your crew, oh is that guy part of it, down there
okay good
alright, get these guys and then we're good
alright
so we're gunna avoid these guys and we're just gunna go for this
let's do this!
LETS DO THIS
lets do this..
*sounding all confident* he can't be that though, how tough could he be
woa.. okay then... *realising he though*
spell casters do not get up all up in his grill that is.. that is the opposite
no that's- that's not what we needed..
'kay cmon..
how tough can he be..
YAY! oh.. he- oh.. OKAY! he's part of my crew now!
when will it end ?!
when will the bloodshed end?!
I guess when- I'm just- gunna push how far this fucking goes then
hoooly shit we're getting uh..
this is a lot !!
this is a lot of people here..
this is a lot of people.
oh! hello! welcome back..okay.
think I just need to wait in the middle
and just let people come to me because I'm- I don't think anyone can actually beat me
hello!
this is the biggest group that I've seen
but I still don't think its gunna be enough
oh they're comin' for me
oh they're ALL comin' for ME
cmon
show me what you got.
show me something good
okay
that's pretty much it, I don't think there's anything else to do because I've been doin' this
for a while and doesn't seem like there's any new creatures
but for a gamejam game
it's an interesting concept
I- *gets distracted* woa.. hey.. hello big guy, welcome to the party
I... I.. I guess you're here now?
maybe there is an end to the game..
but either way if there is an end I don't have the patience to get to it
cause I've been playing this for a while now
and I don't know when it's gunna be over
and I seem to be losing a lot of people- woap, never- nevermind
there be more people
so either way you can play this for yourself through the link in the description below
I'm pretty sure this game is free
it's fun
and hey the developers should improve on this concept because it's an interesting idea
and there's a lot of potential here so
Thank You everybody so much for watching let me know what you thought in the comments below
and let me know if you play it and if there's anything beyond what we see right now
so Thanks again everybody and as always I will see you. In the next video! BYE BYE!- actually..
I just thought of it- a multiplayer version of this game would be
so much fun like it's kind of like i-it's kind of like agario in the concept that you just grow bigger from taking from other people
but the concept is there and this is- this could be really cool in a multiplayer game
so either way, yea
that's all I wanted to say
okay bye!
I have exams to study for and assignments to do but damn finishing the subtitles for Mark's video was so much more fun ^^
Hope you have a nice day, person who is watching this far after the video is done <3